There are some additional advanced features of class models. Four that I'd like
to just briefly mention are interfaces, parametrized classes, nested classes,
and composite objects. If you're familiar with an object-oriented language like
Java, you know that you can express in your program,
a type by using the interface construct within Java.
In UML you can also have interfaces. And in those interface descriptions,
you typically describe what that interface provides to the rest of
the system and what it requires from the rest of the system.
Parameterized classes correspond to Java generics or
C++ templates. That is, that is they provide a way of, for example,
describing collection classes by giving a parameter that is a type of the class.
You have a set of vehicles, you have a set of bank accounts. Thirdly,
our nested classes. If you're familiar with Java,
you know that within a Java class definition, you can have other classes.
These are sometimes called nested classes or inner classes. And
UML provides a feature for describing those situations. Finally, you can have
composite objects. These are objects that contain other objects within them.
Diagram allows you to express this by having class diagrams that have
class rectangles that have other class rectangles in them. As I said,
these are advanced features just so that you're aware that they're there.